[Music]
so I'd like to tell you today as best I
can in 45 minutes in non-technical terms
the story of how scientists with a very
key contribution from Henry Kendall as
you'll see figured out some of nature's
deepest and most beautiful secrets in
1931 after two decades or so of the most
remarkable progress in physics in all of
history
the model of atoms that we still use
today emerged this was the era of
quantum mechanics and the model of atoms
that arose was that atoms consist of a
positively charged nucleus where most
which is very small and which is where
most of the mass of the particle of the
atom is concentrated surrounded by a
cloud of electrons which are all
negatively charged and fill up a big
space and I've tried to crudely into in
a cartoon fashion indicate here that
they're both waves and particles but I
won't even attempt to explain that here
this is not drawn to scale and the atom
of course is much smaller in fact the
nucleus has a size of about ten to the
minus thirteen centimeters which is very
very small not only in absolute terms
but even compared to the size of atoms
atoms are about ten thousand
or a hundred thousand times larger than
the nucleus inside since for most
purposes you can consider atoms as the
indivisible units of matter and
certainly in chemistry they're so
considered it's very difficult to probe
the inside of atoms using chemical or
ordinary means one needs to go to some
extraordinary lengths to probe the
inside of atoms and it's a it's I think
a miracle even in retrospect that it
could be done and figured out but in
1931 when the problem of understanding
the inside of the atom the nucleus
really took its modern shape it was
appropriate to draw us as drawn here as
a black box then the first breakthrough
in understanding what this black box
consisted of was made by one of the
people in this picture James Chadwick
you can probably guess which one it is
I'll give you a hint it's the one who
looks very satisfied with himself first
Chadwick discovered the called the
neutron and with that discovery it
became clear that the nucleus of atoms
could be considered as made up out of
two out of two basic building blocks two
more elementary building blocks protons
and neutrons protons had been known
before although not their essential
nature as the nuclei of hydrogen atoms
but neutrons were are unstick single
neutrons are unstable and had to be
discovered many many many years later by
Chadwick in 1931-32 maurice tells me
it won't be essential for what follows
so at that time in 1931 or two the
problem of understanding protons and
neutrons rose to the top of the physics
agenda physicists had understood atoms
at least in principle and the the
frontier was to understand this deep
inside this deeply mysterious black box
of very small and seemingly inaccessible
the atomic nuclei it soon became clear
that essentially new physical laws would
be involved in understanding atomic
nuclei and in particular what held them
together the known forces at that time
the gravitational and the electric
forces clearly wouldn't do the job the
electric forces in fact would tend to
make the nuclei blow apart because like
charges attract and I'm sorry like
charges repel and one has lots of
positively charged protons and the
neutrons have no electric charge at all
and and gravity is just much too weak
acting on such small amounts of matter
so a basically new force was realized to
be involved and got to be called a
strong force because it's the strongest
force in nature it takes the strongest
force of nature to pose these people
make these particles against the will of
electromagnetism congregate together in
a very very small volume so to figure
out what these forces were first people
just collided protons and neutrons and
tried to measure how they deflected each
other and from that infer that the
forces were and what resulted from those
efforts over many years by many
physicists was that the forces were
extraordinarily complicated people were
perhaps hoping that they'd find some
simple analog of the one over R squared
forces that characterize gravity or
electromagnetism but they found instead
complicated forces that seem to depend
on distance in a complicated way
dependent on how the particles were
spinning on the on and on the energy in
a complicated way and just didn't seem
to be simple at all so they had the
bright idea of trying to look inside the
protons themselves or somehow find
substructure in the protons and hoping I
guess we're just just to find out what
was going on but hoping I suppose to
find simplicity in some smaller bits out
of which protons were made just as the
forces between atoms are very
complicated but reflect the fact that in
atoms you have many electrons
interacting all together and that gives
you chemistry out of fundamental
fundamentally simple interactions
between individual electrons but if the
hope was for finding something simple by
banging the protons and neutrons
together and finding simpler things
coming out the result was a nightmare
because what you find when you collide
protons or neutrons at high energy is
that more comes out then went in so
instead of things getting simpler you
find out this completely novel situation
in physics that you get the same stuff
plus more and things get instead of
simpler nightmarishly more complicated
this is really a equals MC squared R it
backwards one is accustomed to thinking
of e equals MC squared as the obtaining
of energy from mass in a nuclear
explosion say you bring together some
nuclei they lose a little bit of mass
and energy is released here we get to
read the equation in
the opposite way we put in a lot of
energy protons moving really fast to
each other and we can get out more mass
than we started with
so typical result when you collide
protons at high energy might be that you
collide two protons and outcomes not
anything simpler but four protons and
antiprotons and even new particles that
were known before anti lambdas in case
and many many more and soon one had
extensive tables the so-called Rosenfeld
tables of all the various unstable
particles that could be America that
could emerge from proton collisions in
addition to protons themselves so this
is well particle physicists in those
days used to carry around something
called the particle data book which was
conveniently made in wallet-sized form
and came with a magnifying glass and it
contained roughly a hundred pages like
this of data about all the different
particles that that were known through a
series of ingenious deductions and
brilliant leaps some order was brought
to this chaos of particles and it was
realized that one could determine one
could rationalize their properties in
terms of a few simpler configurations of
hypothetical sub structures that is all
these different particles could be
understood as being different
realizations of a few basic
configurations of a smaller number much
smaller number of particles the smaller
number of particles are the are the were
called quarks and the different kinds of
particles that were observed were May
which consists of a quark and you see
this is this thing which is a missing
quark is an anti quark or out of three
quarks which make a so-called baryon or
three anti quarks I didn't want to draw
these complicated things three times
these are the anti baryons made out of
three anti quarks and then there were
three different kinds of quarks up down
and strange and by having the quarks
move in different ways or be vibrating
in different ways one could account for
the vast number of particles that were
observed many people contributed to this
picture but perhaps the most numerous
contributions were made by this fellow
whose Murray that's Murray gell-mann
he'll he'll play a role in a joke to
come but although this rationalized the
vast proliferation of particles to a
certain extent there was a very big
weakness in this modeling no quarks you
had sometimes a quark and an antiquark
sometimes three quarks sometimes three
anti quarks but never a single quark and
certainly no theory of the forces in
fact they'd have to be some very very
peculiar forces so that quarks couldn't
get out even though they were in and of
course I've simplified the story this
fact that the quarks weren't observed
and that there was no theory of the
forces that might hold them together
made some people skeptical
and they were various competing ideas in
fact there was a lot of frustration this
was the period when some physicists got
involved in analogies with Buddhism and
Hinduism and the DAO of physics and the
early days of string theory and other
things in retrospect it's clear that
what was missing was the right tool and
this turned out to be the right tool to
clarify the situation this is the 2-mile
linear accelerator at SLAC if you or it
is slack I'm sorry at Stanford wherever
it is and if you notice the change in
topography there this is cleverly built
over the San Andreas Fault but it's but
it's accurately linear it's no longer
over the San Andreas Fault I'm told
[Laughter]
here it is in late with later editions
and in color from the web and using this
tool which I'll explain a little bit in
a moment three heroes professor Taylor
who's in the audience today and
professor Friedman who I believe is in
the audience also and professor Kendall
who we've been remembering and honoring
today along with many others but they
spearheaded the experiments
that took the understanding of the
strong interaction to a new level
basically this new instrument is a very
sophisticated form of microscope you see
to study the structure of atoms let
alone atomic nuclei using ordinary light
is totally insufficient ordinary light
has a wavelength which is much much
larger than this the atom let alone the
nucleus and so when you try to see it
it's like well it's it can't be done
the resolution is just too poor those of
us over a certain age will know what it
means you need short wavelengths to
resolve small structures and to get
sufficiently short wavelength photons
that translates into very high energies
and very large momentum transfers and
the way to produce such photons such is
to accelerate electrons and allow them
to collide with other charged particles
those collisions are mediated by
so-called virtual profoto pne's
who's whose energy and momentum and
wavelength you can infer from how much
the electron is deflected and by
sophisticated analysis of these
scattering events you can employ these
photons as a precise tool to look inside
the protons and neutrons
and what Taylor Freedman Kendall and
their associates found when they looked
deep inside protons and neutrons was
that there were smaller things inside
that seemed to have very simple
structure where the charge was
concentrated so the protons and neutrons
were not cloudy objects with the
distribution of charge but objects with
little pellets of charge inside this
interpretation of what they were finding
was pioneered by this fellow professor
Fineman and also by Professor burek hain
who's in the audience Fineman called the
things inside protons
partin's this and he had a simple and
bold theory that Parton's should be very
very simple and used them to analyze the
results of these experiments
successfully Fineman and Gelman were
great rivals they were both professors
at Caltech and Gelman hated Parton's
especially mainly he hated the word of
course he didn't hate part times my
first and I can tell a little personal
story here my first one of my first
experiences in physics and my first
encounter with Gelman was in Aspen in
the summer of 1973 and being a young and
naive student I made the mistake of
mentioning that I was working on
Parton's and I was treated to an
unbelievable tirade Parton's Parton's
what what are part times
oh you mean put on put on those things
Fineman talks about they're just quarks
you know there's no such thing
okay so Gelman also has a license plate
on that that says quarks one of these
vanity plates
so that very night I cut out a piece of
cardboard in the plate in the in the
shape of a license plate
I wrote part ons and stuck it on
[Laughter]
unfortunately I think the wind blew I
don't not sure if he ever saw it anyway
to be fair Marie wasn't the only one who
had trouble with part ons because the
interpretation finally was using was
assuming that these particles inside
whatever they were had very very simple
ideal the ideal these simple properties
in fact too damn simple they couldn't be
reconciled with other things we knew
about the general principles of quantum
mechanics this is a little bit subtle
but please bear with me because it's
really the heart of the story why do I
say
these particles shouldn't be couldn't be
too simple and it was paradoxical that
they seemed to be as simple as they were
well it goes back to a phenomenon that
we learn about in elementary
electromagnetism and has been known
since the 19th century that if you have
particles that charged particles in a
medium there's a phenomenon of screening
so for instance if you have positively
charged particles put a positively
charged particle inside a medium that
contains polarizable molecules the
molecules will tend to deform the
negative parts of the molecule will move
towards it will be electrically
attracted towards the positive test
charge all over and as a result that
charge will tend to be neutralized this
is what we call screening so the charge
you see if you're far away in a medium
is partially canceled by the medium
itself and you see a smaller charge we
say or conversely if you go closer and
closer and look finer and finer you
should see a bigger and bigger charge
well what does that have to do with
scattering of elementary particles which
after all don't seem to be in a medium
well actually in our modern
understanding of quantum theory and
so-called empty space really is a medium
there are quantum fluctuations going on
all the time where virtual particles and
antiparticles live for a short time and
then really so I can draw the same sort
of picture as I draw in a medium but now
with the axes being space and time
instead of just space two different
directions in space so if I have a
positive test charge which just sits at
one place in space but lives along what
we call its world line moving along in
time it will polarize the virtual
particles and we can have exactly this
sort of the same sort of screening
effect so the normal expectation is that
in any kind of theory that obeys the
laws of quantum mechanics one should
have this kind of screening effect and
therefore as one moves closer and closer
to elementary particles especially if
they're strongly interacting there's a
strong force among them as we know the
strong force has to be one should get
big screening effects that's certainly
how it would be if the strong force were
just a heftier version of ordinary
electricity and magnetism but what
Taylor Friedman and Kendall saw and what
Fineman and Birkin were using was no
structure at short distances so things
weren't getting more complicated the one
wasn't peeling away some screening to
see a bigger and bigger charge at short
distances in fact one was seeing
something with ideally simple properties
at short distances so instead of the
implication I mean the implication of
screening which seemed to be the general
phenomenon one should expect in quantum
field theory is that the closer you look
the more complicated things should look
but the experiments showed a gift from
heaven the closer you looked the simpler
things behaved so one wanted a theory
with the opposite behavior of anti
screening now since the heuristic
explanation I showed you a screening is
so simple I hope you won't find it
implausible that it's very difficult to
find theories that have the opposite
behavior however we found that there are
such theories in fact there's almost
only an essence there's only one such
theory so from this very very general
kind of consideration one has led to
almost a unique theory of what the
strong interaction has to be and it
turns out that the theory one has led to
is a generalization of electromagnetism
it's now called quantum chromodynamics
or QCD the essence of which is that
unlike a it's a generalization of
electromagnetism but with a very
important twist we'll come to in a
moment it's a generalization with three
different kinds of charges they're
called colors of course they have
nothing to do with ordinary color
they're just three different kinds of
charge they also have nothing to do with
electric charge but they're 3d but they
are the things that
that photons care about but what gluons
care about now if one just had three
copies of electromagnetism one would
still have screening and one wouldn't
have advanced at all in this problem
however when you have three different
colors there's another pot there's
another class of things that can happen
not only can you have photons that
respond individually to the colored
charges but you also have the
possibility of one color turning into
another and there's a richer theory
which is what QCD is and which one
includes not only gluons which sense the
different charges which would be
analogous to the photon but also other
kinds of gluons which actually change
one kind of color charge into another so
instead of having three photons it turns
out you have eight and some quick-witted
person should ask me later why there are
not nine but I will save that for a
question now that difference these that
possibility of one color changing into
another and these new Kuip types of
gluons change the qualitative theory of
the qualitative nature of the theory
quite substantially because now unlike
in the case of photons which are
electrically neutral the gluons
themselves carry the charges so for
instance this gluon which changes green
charge into red charge itself has one
unit of green charge and minus one unit
of red charge so that when it does the
changing the charges can be conserved
and the consequence of this since that
gluons respond to color charge and at
the same time carry color charge is that
gluons interact with each other let me
bring this down to earth a bit well let
me bring it closer to experience many of
you have probably seen the movie Star
Wars the original one and laser sword
fights play a very prominent role in
Star Wars well in the real world lazy
laser sword fights would be very dubious
affairs because photons don't interact
with other photons so these laser beams
would just merrily pass right through
one another of course it's a futuristic
movie and perhaps those lasers are
actually lays in color gluons then it
would work with colored gluons they
would really clash against these
explosions presumably but there's a big
difference so photons go through each
other's gluons interact with each other
and it's much more intricate then to
understand what happens when you have
the possibility of screening because the
gluons cannot oh the gluons themselves
can move around the charge distribute it
in different ways and if I had another
hour I could probably make it plausible
to you that this phenomenon actually
lives leads to anti screening but I'll
have to leave it at that it does by
calculation
okay so one has gluons that interact
with each other and then the interaction
among the quarks which is ultimately
responsible for the existence of protons
and maisons and the structure of all the
strongly interacting particles is
supposed to be due at its core
elementary the elementary process that
underlies it is simply the exchange of
these coloured gluons so it's a sort of
vast but recognizable generalization of
what we know about in electrodynamics
well since this theory was formulated
it's been tested in many ways one thing
that's happened is we progress from
linear colliders to circular ones much
and and higher energies and at this
elect large electron positron ring near
Geneva and that many other accelerators
one has been able to test the theory
which was first invented just to
understand the Kendyl at all experiments
to work out its implications for all
kinds of other experiments and here you
see what to me is the most beautiful
graph in all of physics which indicates
the data from a large number of
different kinds of experiments each of
these data many of these data points
represent the results of hundreds of
independent measurements and the anti
screening effect which one can calculate
in the theory is the fact that this
curve goes up this way so that it
well at higher energies which correspond
to shorter distances the effective
strength of the strong interaction is
getting smaller and smaller so this this
one is plotted in increasing energy
which is the same it turns out as
smaller and smaller distances
so we have I think what's fair to call
compelling evidence that this theory is
the correct theory of the strong
interaction there's lots of data that
agrees with it and nothing that
contradicts it it's had to it's had
several remarkable consequences outside
of the original problem of understanding
the strong interaction one is that
cosmology the study of the very early
moments of the Big Bang
gets easy it used to be very mysterious
what would happen when you press matter
closer and closer together because we
knew that protons and provacative very
complicated ways with each other and it
seemed to be a very that most of the
most powerful force and we had no idea
what would happen under those
circumstances and in the Big Bang in the
earliest moments of the Big Bang when
it's concerned with the properties of
matter at extraordinarily high
temperatures and densities and that's
precisely what wasn't known but now
we've learned that that's exactly when
physics gets simple again it's when the
particles are close together or at high
energies that the effective strength of
the strong interaction which was the
difficult thing to treat gets weak where
you get inside those anti screening
clouds the vast buildup of charge goes
away and you see the elementary charges
which are smaller so cosmology has
gotten much easier than it used to be
and with remarkable results including
the possibility of formulating the
so-called inflationary model of the
universe due to professor Guth here at
MIT
another thing that's happened is that
it's been possible to formulate much
more concrete ideas about the
unification of
all the forces of nature this is due to
two effects first of all as I've alluded
to several times before this theory of
the strong interaction very much
resembles the theory of electromagnetism
there's also a theory of the weak
interaction which I haven't said
anything about it's another interaction
which also resembles those two they're
all different but but you can see a
family resemblance among them since
they're mathematically so similar they
all involve gluons which act on
different kinds of charges in fact there
are five different kinds of charges if
you put them all together it's hard to
resist the temptation to imagine that
there's a unified theory where you have
gluons that change all five different
kinds of charges into one another
the difficulty with that idea at first
sight is that the strength of the
different interactions seems very
different that's why one of them is
called the weak interaction another one
is called the strong interaction however
we've learned that the strength of the
interaction you measure at some distance
is not necessarily going to be its
strength at another distance and one has
to do a calculation to extrapolate what
the behavior is going to be when you get
to the heart of the matter at very short
distances so one can still hope and test
by calculation that the different
interactions which look so different at
the distances we measure might turn out
to be the same at much smaller distances
and it turns out to a remarkable extent
that works out one can extrapolate this
very same calculation that leads to the
measured change in the couplings where
we can measure it to much shorter
distances and then one finds that indeed
the strong weak and electromagnetic
interactions do become unified if well
it works more or less if we include only
the known part
if we also include the supersymmetric
particles which are very popular
although not yet observed then they meet
perfectly so we're very encouraged that
we're on the right track both with the
idea that the different forces get
unified and with the idea that one
should have supersymmetry as an
unexpected bonus even gravity seems to
fall into place
so the story of the strong interaction
has most unexpectedly had ramifications
in cosmology and the unification of the
forces of nature but there are also
challenges and opportunities that remain
in the study of the strong interaction
itself that I think are no less
remarkable let me first mention two
slogans from John Wheeler who's a
physicist a very famous physicist at
Princeton I guess we regard him as our
patron saint similar to Viki Weisskopf
at MIT he's very good at coining catchy
phrases and two that I really like and
apply to qcdr it's from bits and mass
without mass it's from bits is the idea
that ideally the laws of nature should
calculate the properties of matter it's
starting only from purely logical or
mathematical properties bits
and that's to a remarkable extent
realized in QCD I showed you a selection
from the table of the vast number of
particles that have been observed in QCD
the masses and properties of all those
particles have to be explained from a
theory that basically contains only two
numbers the number three which is the
number of colors and the number two
which is the number of relevant quarks
that is the U and the D cork so it
really is it's from bits when produce
vast amount of structure from purely
logical and elementary numerical
properties of course to get from those
simple numbers the three and the two to
this table requires a lot of processing
in between and some of the world's most
elaborate numerical simulations on
massively calc massively parallel tel
teraflop computers have been employed in
that effort
another of wheelers slogans is mass
without mass this refers to the idea
that again
it's a equals MC squared or rather MC
squared equals or rather I should say M
equals E over C squared that you can get
mass starting with pure energy without
putting any mass in that's exactly what
happens in QCD and it's actually what we
believe but all sane physicists now
believe is true of the proton for
instance most of the mass of the proton
comes not from the mass of the things
that are inside but from the mass from
the energy in the fields that bind them
together the quarks and the gluons have
very small or zero masses so
implementing these slogans in detail to
get from the ideal theory to concrete
predictions about the world is an
ongoing challenge which is worthy and is
receiving of a great deal of effort
another area in which we can hope to do
much better and we've made remarkable
progress in the last couple of years is
in the study of very dense matter it
turns out perhaps not surprisingly but
in detail it is surprising that if you
put if you press quarks very close
together things simplify and one can
start to actually solve the equations of
QCD fairly simply whereas in general
they're very difficult to solve and
require massive numerical work well this
is extremely interesting work and has
led to I think a very beautiful result
let me just try to give you the flavor
of it by saying that the central
prediction of this theory is that deep
inside every neutron star when the
quarks get pressed really really close
together they look like a diamond they
become a transparent insulating material
so it's the diamond inside as big as the
Ritz
inside each neutron star so I think the
quest to understand the strong
interaction which started as sort of
just unpeeling the next layer in the
onion of understanding the structure of
matter has been a truly remarkable
success story in which Henry Kendall
played a central role it's story that's
not yet over but I hope I hope I've
given you some flavor of what we've
achieved so far thank you
okay thanks thank you thank you Frank
for beautiful talk and thank all the
other I thank all the other speakers
today the panelists and also you who are
there who no question are here to honor
Henry
[Applause]